olá eu quando recebi o convite para
estar aqui
a primeira reação que eu tive foi medo
eu tive muito medo porque não porque não
não porque essa seja a primeira vez que
eu vá palestrar e falar mas porque é um
público muito diferente do que eu tô
acostumada
eu sou do rio de janeiro e lá eu faço
parte de um grupo que faz atividades em
escolas com crianças ea maior parte
dessas dessas atividades elas são feitas
em escolas públicas
então é bem diferente estar com as
crianças e adolescentes e hoje está aqui
num lugar tão grande mas esse medo ele
começou a passar logo assim que eu
cheguei eu cheguei no aeroporto e aí eu
passei numa banca de jornal e vi várias
capas de revista né me trouxeram 11
promovendo mas a eu sei onde estou mas
também remeteu uma lembrança um pouco
mais antiga eu lembrei da época que eu
estava no ginásio e aí todas as minhas
amigas elas
teve uma época que começaram a
colecionar essas revistas cíntia não é
que hoje até um pouquinho - é e aí eu
lembro de sempre na hora do intervalo as
minhas amigas estarem trocando revistas
estarem olhando e amorosos como olha que
ele está e sizinhos olha as meninas da
capa e e nunca eu nunca consegui me
relacionar com aquelas meninas que
estavam nas revistas era sempre muito
distantes de mim
algumas amigas até conseguiam se
relacionar porque tinha alguma
similaridade eu nunca tinha similaridade
com com essa revista é com todas as
revistas cinzas
ia e quando não era no intervalo quando
a gente estava voltando para casa
a gente também via tinha que parar na
banca de jornal para poder ficar vendo
essas revistas é em esse foi um momento
bem complicado porque todo mundo sabe
essa transição de criança para a
adolescente
a gente busca referências a gente busca
o que é bonito que é belo pra que a
gente possa se arrumar de outra forma se
comportar desta forma diferente das
minhas amigas eu não tinha essa relação
não conseguia ver esse exemplo
afirmativo né de beleza que se parecesse
comigo é tudo mudou
neto teve um dia que eu estava em casa
assistindo mtv e aí foi como um abrir de
olhos e eu comecei a amin tenderia a
viver de uma outra forma
eu vi essa imagem essa a maioria das
pessoas com mais ou menos a minha idade
devem saber quem é
elbe dos pais e crianças e quando eu a
via de um clique na minha cabeça
e aí eu estava vendo um outro modelo de
beleza
o modelo de beleza que estava mais
parecido comigo
ameobi ela representou na minha vida um
despertar na época eu devia ter uns 12
13 anos não sei ao certo é mais ali já
começava a mudar alguma coisa em minha
já comecei a querer outras coisas
logo depois de ter visto o meu bi
eu pedi uma coisa pra minha mãe eu pedi
para que eu fizesse um permanente afro
foi um desastre porque permanente afro
não era feita naquela época em 20
minutos
eu ficava no salão cinco horas eu usava
um creme que tinha um cheiro horroroso
eu usava uma pecinha de metal chamada
bigodinho
e com esse produto que tinha um cheiro
muito ruim aquele metal esquentava
esquentava a minha cabeça
então todas aquelas cinco horas que eu
passava dentro do salão me faziam muito
mal porque o resultado não era bom eu
fiz a primeira vez três meses depois fiz
de novo e aí acho que na terceira ou
quarta vez eu já não fiz mais eu queria
saber tudo que eu sei hoje porque eu
teria poupado uma grande parte do
orçamento dos meus pais porque
sinceramente foi dinheiro jogado fora
porque eu não conseguia ser como ela eu
queria alguma coisa que eu não sabia o
que era mas eu já sabia que ela era um
dos meus modelos no futuro
ela também foi responsável por uma outra
coisa na minha vida
ela foi a primeira boneca preta que
houve nessa época eu tinha 27 bonecas
que poderiam parecer com ela mas não
pareciam eram todas as bonecas brancas
de cabelo louro liso mas eu consegui ter
uma dela né
hoje em dia eu tenho outras
possibilidades mas na época ela era que
eu queria
quase dez anos depois quando eu fiz 23
anos
eu decidi que eu não iria mais alisar o
cabelo é por três meses eu fiquei me
escondendo falando pra minha mãe que eu
realizar mas não realizava e aí ficava é
postergando essa esse momento nas
realizar
e aí eu decidi falei pra ela mãe eu não
vou mais alisar o cabelo foi um momento
bem difícil não só com a minha mãe que
ela acha ela sentia que era um fio dela
porque ela que cuidava sempre foi minha
mãe que cuida do meu cabelo mas foi um
rompimento porque tudo
aquilo que eu vivi a minha vida toda eu
estava começando a fazer diferente e é
um caminho que eu ia trilhar separado
dela eu espero que a gente trilha um
caminho junto daqui a pouco porque eu
acho que minha mãe vai ficar crespo como
eu
e aí eu comecei a pesquisar sobre cabelo
nem quando eu falei pra ela eu não ia
mais realizar porque ficar com o cabelo
crespo é uma decisão bem difícil
eu sempre tive esse cabelo alisado eu
não tinha idéia de como era o meu fio eu
não tinha idéia que tipo de de percalços
eu passaria pra poder me sentir bonita
eu só sabia que eu ia ter o meu cabelo
crespo e aí eu comecei a pesquisar
enlouquecidamente em todos os blogs em
todos os grupos em todos os lugares e eu
encontrei várias mulheres que estavam ou
passando nesse por esse processo ou
então que já se entendiam mulheres três
tipos mais queriam trocar essas
experiências e aí eu encontrei o hoje
conhecido como coletivo meninas black
power
hoje nós somos oito mulheres no rio de
janeiro e no espírito santo
e nós fazemos esse trabalho educativo
nas escolas
toda essa idéia de beleza de
pertencimento no mundo é a gente
transforma isso em oficinas ea gente vai
para essas escolas para falar sobre o
pigmento crescia sobre o período de de
libertação do nosso povo da força do
nosso povo a gente fala da lei 10.639
que é uma lei mas não é aplicada nas
escolas
então a gente usa o fio do cabelo que
todo mundo pensar ah é só mais um grupo
estiloso que vem aqui falar de cabelo
mas quando a gente ama
na escola a gente vai falar com as
crianças de possibilidades de
crescimento de poder que é quando a
gente diz
existe alguém que existem cientistas
pretas existem médicos pretas e ea gente
mostra isso para as crianças como
possibilidade como um objetivo que elas
podem alcançar uma coisa que eu não
contei pra vocês é que eu sou
especialista em criminalística forense
eu sou formada pelos eua sai o miami new
york e numa dessas a hoje que a gente
sempre tem
é um dos personagens contou uma coisa
que me marcou profundamente é eles
encontravam numa enfim no momento que a
os restos que eles encontraram não tinha
ossos não tinha dna não tinha nada a
única coisa que tinha era cabelo e eles
todos estavam desesperados para saber o
que aconteceu com aquela pessoa e aí
disseram alguém disse
então vamos estudar o cabelo o fio desse
cabelo e pelo fim desse cabelo eles
conseguiram identificar o sexo em que
período essa pessoa viveu a média de
idade dessa pessoa a dieta dessa pessoa
quando vi aquilo eu fiquei chocada como
de um cabelo um fio um fio pode carregar
tanta história
quando eu comecei a esse processo de
ficar de voltar a ser três pan eu
coloquei trança e aí quando a menina que
fez as tranças estava colocando eu
toquei na trança ea sensação da copa
daquele fio sintético que a gente chama
de planejar long era igual
ao que eu tinha na minha cabeça eu
maltratei o meu cabelo com tanta química
tanto a progressiva ao ponto daquele fio
ser igual a um fio sintético
quando ouve e sai e lembrei dessa
sensação eu falei tá tudo errado e se eu
ficar crespa não é só pro ser estilosa
ser bonita eu estou carregando muita
história toda essa história ela não foi
só nesse momento desse cabelo que
parecia plástico
eu comecei a fazer disso um hábito
eu comecei de todos os dias ao invés de
pentear o cabelo eu começava a sentir e
eu colocava a mão no meu fio e aí eu
senti a ele dessa outra forma
quando a gente vai nas escolas
essa é uma das oficinas que a gente faz
com as crianças
a gente sempre pede para que as crianças
tomem consciência do que é isso
desse fio desse cabelo
esse cabelo que conta uma história não é
simplesmente algo que tá ali pra
enfeitar
é uma história é a minha história de
ancestralidade é a história dos meus
avós dos meus pais
é a minha própria história porque se
hoje eu estou me alimentando bem se hoje
eu não estou colocando produtos químicos
agressivos no meu cabelo se hoje eu tô
tomando bastante água ou não isso tudo
está gravado no fim do meu cabelo
então eu vou convidar vocês agora pra
poder fazer parte disso junto comigo
queria pedir para que vocês tocassem o
fio de cabelo e aí vocês sentirem o que
é isso
tipo de cuidados a gente está tendo com
que a nossa né porque nasci e aí sente
de verdade esse toque essa necessidade
desse fio o que ele está dizendo qual é
a sua história o que seu cabelo precisa
que você faça para que ele seja melhor e
mais saudável
pra que ele não simplesmente esteja te a
dor nando mas pra que vocês sejam uma
coisa só
esse é o trabalho que o coletivo meninas
black power faz
e essa é apenas uma das mudanças que fez
na minha vida
fez com que eu começasse a partir do fio
do cabelo a me entender como uma pessoa
diferente a me entender como uma pessoa
completa
muito obrigada